what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another song of ice and fire
theory video
if you have been watching my channel as
of lately then you would know that i
have been making videos on each chapter
from each book
in one of my most recent videos i
discussed bran stark's first chapter in
a song of ice and fire
one of the main events from that chapter
is when house stark discovers the dire
wolves in the late summer snows
in that video i said the way that jon
snow finds ghost has always been very
interesting to me because of a few small
details that we are given
even if you have only seen the game of
thrones show you would know that jon
does not find ghost right away
he doesn't actually hear a ghost until
he is walking away but it happens
somewhat differently
in the books when jon hears ghost in the
books he's actually much farther away
when he's riding his horse across the
bridge yet somehow he is still able to
hear a ghost
although we know that ghost is known for
never making a sound
there are mentions of this in the books
we know that ghost does not bark like
the others do
and ghost is also known to be very
silent on his feet
even when he's much bigger than when jon
found him this has always made me wonder
how jon was able to hear him when no one
else
did i think i know how this happened but
i will be honest
this is somewhat of a crazy theory but
all i ask is for you to hear me out
until the end
because i believe i do have some
interesting evidence to back it all up
shall we begin like i said in that
brainstorm video
this scene has to be one of the most
important moments in all of the books
according to george rr martin this was
the very first scene that he thought of
which went on to inspire this incredible
story that we all know and love so much
this is also a very significant moment
because it does foreshadow some major
events in the story
so for you this creation began back in
1991
and i know that's a while ago but i'm
hoping you can remember for us
the scene or the image that launched the
series
a song of ice and fire it was the it was
the first chapter of uh
the novel game of thrones not not the
prologue which
actually appears first i wrote that
later but it was the uh the chapter
where they
uh bran viewpoint and they write out to
see the
the desert are beheaded and then they
find the direwolf pups in uh
in the summer snow the image of the dead
stag and dead dire wolf was a great
representation of what would eventually
happen to houses baratheon
and stark this has to make you wonder
did they discover them by accident
or were the starks meant to have them
like jon snow said
i think it's safe to say that most of us
think it was bloodraven
and the children of the forest who sent
them to house stark
not only to keep them safe but also
guide them on their journey
so they will end up exactly where they
need them to be for when the white
walkers invade westeros again
now there are some fans who say bran
stark might have even influenced this
event himself
maybe he set things in motion inside the
weirwood net
so they would find the direwolves on
that day either way
there is really only one thing i want to
focus on in this video
how this direwolf made it south of the
wall is a conversation we can save for a
later day
i want to discuss how jon snow found
ghost what actually made him go back
and look again i think bran stark from
the future
assisted john in finding ghost now let
me explain what i mean by that
first let me show you why i think
someone or something
connected to the old gods assisted in
this discovery
this will show you that someone or
something made sure the starks found
the direwolves at that moment let us
have a look at one of lady catelyn's
chapters because i think this is where
we get some interesting information
in her chapter she says that is no
common wolf for that one
the great john's been heard to say that
the old gods of the north sent those
dire wolves to your children
catelyn remembered the day when her boys
had found the pups in the late summer
snows
there had been five three male and two
female for the five true born children
of house stark
and a sixth white of fur and red of eye
for ned's bastard son jon snow
no common wolves she thought no indeed
when you think about it
what are the odds of the starks finding
the exact amount of dire wolves for each
of the children
not only did they find the right number
but the genders matched as well
that does not seem like a coincidence to
me lady catlin knew that her kids were
meant to have them
in another one of her chapters she says
something else that i find to be very
interesting
she said any man grey one mislikes is a
man i do not want close to you
these wolves are more than wolves rob
you must know that
i think perhaps the god sent them to us
your father's gods
the old gods of the north now if you
remember when they were found we also
heard jon snow say something very
similar
he knew that the starks were meant to
have them as well later in the books
john begins to realize there is
something very special about ghost
in that chapter john says red eyes john
realized
but not like melisandre's he had a
weirwood's eyes
red eyes red mouth white fur blood and
bone
like a heart tree he belongs to the old
gods this one
and he alone of all the dire wolves was
white six pups they'd found in the late
summer snows him and rob
five that were gray and black and brown
for the five starks
and one white as white as snow he had
his answer then
so now there is more than one stark who
believes the dire wolves were led to
them from the old gods
also based on what jon just said about
ghost
i think that gives us a direct
connection to bloodraven who is also
described to have those same features of
skin that look like bone
and eyes that look like blood it says
white as bone were the skin and hair of
brendan rivers
in his eye he had only one the other
having been lost to his half-brother
bittersteel
on the red grass field was red as blood
so this could be another sign that
bloodraven and the children of the
forest sent the starks these dire wolves
bloodraven has the same colors as a
heart tree which is the same thing
john thinks whenever he looks at ghost
now let's go back to the scene in which
john found ghost
make sure you focus on all the details
right here because as i said before
i believe this is when we get some
evidence that may suggest
brian stark from the future made sure
jon went back to have a second look for
ghost
after they find the five original
direwolves in the snow
they begin to leave to head back to
winterfell but this is when jon hears
something that no one else seems to
notice
let's see what it says in the book it
was not until they were mounted and on
their way that bran allowed himself to
taste the sweet
air of victory by then his pup was
snuggled inside of his leathers
warm against him safe for the long ride
home
bran was wondering what to name him
halfway across the bridge
john suddenly stops his horse what is it
john
their lord father asked can't you hear
it
bran could hear the wind in the trees
the clatter of their hooves on the iron
wood planks
the whimpering of his hungry direwolf
but john was listening to something else
now make sure you remember the details
we were given so far
they are already halfway across the
bridge the horses have to be making a
lot of noise
from their hooves hitting the iron wood
planks on that bridge
yet as i have said before john was
somehow
able to hear ghost who is known for not
making a sound
also remember what it says bran is able
to hear during all of this
the first thing it says bran hears is
the wind in the trees
remember that line specifically because
i will reference that again and again
now let's go back to the scene in the
book there
john said he swung his horse around and
galloped back across the bridge
they watched him dismount where the
direwolf laid dead in the snow watched
him kneel
a moment later he was writing back to
them smiling
he must have crawled away from the
others john said alright now let's break
this scene down
because something very interesting
happened here obviously
the first thing we need to ask is how
the hell did john here ghost
jon is riding with a large group of men
who all have their own horses
all of these horses are making a lot of
noise as their hooves slap against the
wood planks on the bridge
it's not until they're halfway across
when jon hears something
but what did jon actually hear the only
thing bran could hear was the wind in
the trees
and the horse's hooves on the bridge but
again somehow john heard it when no one
else did
later in the books john even says to
himself
he's not like the others john said he
never makes a sound
that's why i named him ghost that and
because he's white
the others are all dark gray or black
let's look at what else it says about
ghost
because this is not the only mention of
that in another one of john's chapters
it says as he went to his knees ghost
lifted his head
his neck glistened wetly but he made no
sound when john took off a glove and
touched him
john notices this over and over again
there has to be a good reason why the
author
frequently wants to remind us of this in
another one of john's chapters
it says it again atop the stones of the
ring wall
ghost hunched with his white fur
bristling he made no sound
but his dark red eyes spoke blood so
again you have to ask yourself if ghost
doesn't make any sounds
what actually happened the day jon found
him what did jon really hear
because based on what we know it could
not have been ghosts that he heard
now let's go back to that scene again so
we can see what they did here
it said it was not until they were
mounted and on their way that brain
allowed himself to taste the sweet air
of victory
by then his pup was snuggled inside his
leathers
warm against him safe for the long ride
home bran was wondering what to name him
halfway across the bridge john suddenly
stops on his horse
what is it john their lord father asked
can't you hear it
bran could hear the wind in the trees
okay so as you can see when jon stops
his horse
ned says what is it john then john says
can't you hear it now john never
actually says what he heard
the safe assumption is he heard ghost
because that's what he finds
but at this time we don't know that
ghost does not make any sounds
the first thing bran notices is the
sound of the wind in the trees
so what does that mean did the author
let us know that because it has some
sort of significance
i think so now you also have to remember
this was the very first scene george rr
martin ever wrote down
the image of the starks finding the
direwolves was the first thing that came
to his mind
so this scene inspired everything else
that was to follow in the later books
now let's go over some of the things
john may have heard
that made him go back and find ghost
besides the sounds the horses were
making that day
all we really know is the sound of the
wind moving through the trees could be
heard as well
if something magical was happening that
day then most would think it would have
been bloodraven or the children of the
forest influencing things since they
were the ones who sent the direwolves
anyway
however maybe jon was already able to
enter the mind of ghost
since ghost did already have his eyes
open if you remember
bran thought it was curious that ghost
would already have his eyes open when
they found them
when all the other direwolves were still
blind maybe this allowed jon to have an
immediate connection to ghost
in the books jon is able to sense ghost
whenever he is nearby
this is also mentioned on several
occasions in one of john's other
chapters
it says ghost was not always with him
but he was never far either
even when they were separated jon could
sense his nearness
he was glad for that so if you want to
say john went back to find ghost because
he could already sense him
i would be fine with that but let's look
at another option
since they found them during bran
stark's chapter i think he may have had
something to do with it
especially when you consider jon said
that he heard something
he did not say that he felt something
also
i think there may have been a good
reason why it said bran heard the wind
moving through the trees that day
what's crazy is it might have actually
been bran who was making the wind do
that
since jon said he heard something i
think he may have heard a whisper a
whisper that came from bran
in the future let me explain
over a year ago i made some videos on
some of my favorite chapters from the
books
one of those videos was on another one
of bran stark's chapters but this
chapter is in the
last book that was written which is the
dance with dragons
in that chapter bran is inside
bloodraven's cave
learning how to see through the
werewoods when this happens
we see bran try to speak to his father
although he knows that his father is
already dead
but when bran looks through the weirwood
he is able to see things that have
happened in the past
now during this scene brain is able to
see several different things when he is
inside the weirwood net
he sees lyanna and benjen having fun in
the godswood
he sees old nan in the godswood when she
is much younger
he also sees something that may have
happened 8 000 years ago
when winterfell was a new castle because
the werewood is so much smaller at that
time
however the one thing i want to focus on
is when bran sees ned stark sitting
under the weirwood
something very interesting happens here
and i think it may explain why bran
first heard the wind moving through the
trees the day john found ghost
when bran looks out through the weirwood
this is what happens
lord eddard stark set upon a rock beside
the deep black pole and the godswood
the pale roots of the heart tree
twisting around him like an
old man's gnarled arms the great sword
ice lay across lord edward's lap
and he was cleaning the blade with an
oil cloth winterfell
brain whispered his father looked up
who's there
he asked turning this actually makes
brain afraid
everything begins to fade away and bran
finds himself
back in bloodraven's cave bran says the
bloodraven
he heard me but bloodraven says
something that sounds very familiar to
what bran heard the day jon finds ghost
bloodraven says he heard a whisper on
the wind
a rustling amongst the leaves ned
obviously heard something because he did
give a reaction to bran whispering
winterfell
now whether ned heard bran or the wind
is up for debate
but i think bloodraven is lying to bran
i happen to believe
ned did hear his voice but bloodraven
doesn't want bran to know that
because he doesn't want bran to have
major influences on different events
we even saw something like this happen
in the tv show
we'll visit again another time i want to
see where he's going time to go
father
now did you happen to see the look on
bloodraven's face when that happened
he says ned did not hear bran but why
does he look so afraid when that
happened
now obviously i don't want to mix up
things from the show
and things from the books but maybe this
was included because they may have
intended to take things in a different
direction at first
maybe they wanted to reveal other things
about brain's influence in the weirwood
net but ultimately decided to go in
another direction
either way ned heard something in the
books as he did in the tv show
when bran whispers to his father ned has
an immediate reaction
so maybe bran attempted to do the same
thing when jon found ghost
maybe there will be a scene in the books
where brain is looking back on that day
and when he notices john try to leave
before he finds ghost
he will whisper something to make jon go
back and look again
let me show you something else that is
interesting from the books because there
are more scenes of brian speaking
through the weirwood
one of these scenes he just so happens
to try to speak to john
in this chapter john is out beyond the
wall when he is with the half hand
as they were out here they stopped for
the night to get some sleep
however when jon goes to sleep he thinks
he's having a dream
but what actually happens is jon slips
inside ghost
jon is inside of ghost looking out his
eyes
this is what happens when he finds a
weirwood john
the call came from behind him softer
than a whisper
but strong too can a shout be silent
he turned his head searching for his
brother for a glimpse of a lean gray
shape moving beneath the trees but there
was nothing
only a weirwood the weirwood had his
brother's face
had his brother always had three eyes
not always
came the silent shout not before the
crow
remember this right here john hears
someone whisper his name
and he thinks it was his brother bran
now we know bran is attempting to speak
through the trees over and over again
this may not be the first time bran
tries to speak to jon either
i want to show you another interesting
example this time bran tries to speak to
theon greyjoy
when he is still in winterfell with the
boltons in this chapter
theon is outside in the godswood in
front of the weirwood
this is what it says theon a voice
seemed to whisper
his head snapped up who said that all he
could see were the trees and the fog
that covered them
the voice had been as faint as rustling
leaves a leaf drifted down from above
brushed his brow and landed in the pool
it floated on the water
red five-fingered like a bloody hand
bran
the tree murmured this is exactly what
bloodraven tried to say
ned heard when brain attempted to speak
to him bloodraven said all he would have
heard was the wind and rustling leaves
but we know these whispers are being
heard theon heard it
john heard it and so did ned now let's
bring this all the way back around to
the scene in which jon finds ghost
was it bloodraven who influenced this
event
was it jon's connection to ghost that
made him look back
again or was bran speaking to jon
through the wind rustling in the trees
john said he heard something
but what did he actually hear let me
know what you think down below
i want to thank everyone for watching
the video if you would like to support
the channel
head on over to my patreon i would
really appreciate that
the link is down below have a great day
everyone
i will see you again very soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
so
you